my top priority is fighting inflation
and lowering prices for families and
things they need we're going to keep
working to fight inflation and lower
cost of to All American families for a
lot of other things as well
Joe Biden trying to turn the political
tide with his presidency in Peril over
inflation bides set to bash Republicans
as voters grow increasingly frustrated
with higher prices a new Gallup poll
shows 52 percent worry about maintaining
their standard of living and 40 percent
stress over paying their bills the
President also facing backlash over a
baby formula shortage retailers now
limiting how many products customers can
buy due to a combination of inflation
supply shortages and product recalls
Jesse you were heavily medicated during
this uh a lot of this stuff so I'm
interested in where you see this going
he's going to speak tomorrow do you have
any thoughts so the Putin price hike is
not working the White House has a new
line of attack they need to sharpen the
contrast with Republicans in the
midterms so you're going to see Biden
getting hyper partisan and just blaming
everything on the right the country's
not buying it we know we printed and
spent way too much money it's without
you shut down the economy and we put all
our supply chains in China so when we
opened back up boom the dollar got
destroyed everybody that has Common
Sense understands that but Biden could
not be in a worse political situation
you can't blame China can't blame the
Fed so this is on him right now he's now
having a looming Global recession a
stock market that looks like it's kind
of shaky inflation at record high and
now there's shortages of not only
electricity Greg but baby formula right
and let me tell you baby formula is very
expensive the average family spends
fifteen hundred dollars a year on baby
formula and so you have a baby formula
recall happening at the same time as
baby formula thievery because you can
get a lot of money on the black market
people are making I think it was like
four thousand dollars a week just
stealing baby formula they have to lock
it up like they do toothpaste now at the
Walgreens and so now they have like
operation Milk Money where the feds have
to go in and bust up these baby formula
ringers it's a really really sad
situation you know if you're not
breastfeeding you'd be out of luck yeah
thank God I'm not well mayor Pete's okay
so Harold in The Green Room you were
just saying I think it's time that Joe
has to resign I was really surprised you
finally said that um what would be your
advice for this week before he does
resign well I didn't say that I think
you might have misheard
the uh look the inflation is is what's
going to be the the centerpiece of the
debate come come fall time for Democrats
and Republicans I think Republicans are
right to raise these issues but they
they won't win unless they offer
Solutions it's easy to say that prices
are up we all know that we all know
we're paying more for things I give the
president more credit this week and I've
called balls and Strikes on him over the
last several weeks I give them credit
for at least traveling outside of
Washington trying to find those examples
of where Investments are working the
fact that we have a javelin production
plant that he went to you can like him
or not I think that was the right thing
to do the fact that he's going to Ohio
to Tout The semiconductor chip plant
these are the things that we have to be
producing not only to unclog the supply
chain but to ensure that we're able to
produce these things here
and then and then you know what I would
focus on that as well crime inflation
and the Border that's all I would be
focused on if I were in this White House
sending this President and Vice
President out to come back with answers
and solutions things that we can not
just gun control and I think that has to
be part of it but Greg you've been the
greatest advocate for mental health
issues that need to be addressed on
streets across the country judge you've
talked about the need uh in a very
serious way around we all had but you
about cash bail reform these things are
out there for Democrats to grab hold to
but we should not kid ourselves people
do not believe economically they're
doing better or going to do better we
have to erase that notion or address
that notion if we're to win judge that
does explain why this Roe v Wade thing
is is because they can't they don't have
an answer for this other stuff well
there's no question about it I mean the
Cure point the the baby formula is more
abortion
yeah I'm not even going to go there but
I I agree with Harold I I do I mean he's
trying to do anything he can to run away
from the fact that everybody knows that
their money isn't buying them would have
bought them last year people are
frightened they're not afraid they're
afraid they're not going to keep the
same standard of living they're they're
afraid that they can't do the things
that they wanted to do they don't have
enough money and every day they go
there's a gas a station it it's a
problem and you know what I think is
incredible I went yesterday because my
daughter brought her baby to the house
and I went yesterday I had to run to the
drugstore which is like a minute away
and I looked for baby formula and CVS
and because Kiki said my daughter Kiki
don't call her that anyway uh she said
they have it in CVS so I'm thinking to
myself CVS that's where they go when
they like just load up everything they
need I mean and of course they had none
at that CBS and so I went to supermarket
they didn't have any oh and so now
apparently
um you know people are hogging it and
then selling it at all kinds of high
prices it's a shame but you know what
Biden can't get away with he can blame
he can blame the devil I don't really
care but people know what the problem
I've seen gangs uh Dana of roving babies
out on the streets just taking just
taking the baby formula from other
babies
yeah I'm eye level it's disgusting so uh
are you changing any of your birthday
plans because of inflation
um no bouncy castle no I haven't landed
a lot to let that one go yeah it was too
expensive you notice one thing though
about how Joe
supposedly has a reputation for empathy
however when it comes to this stuff like
that this it's always like these things
will pass yeah
so we've talked before about how they
don't listen to us but they don't have
an early warning system at the White
House of like this is going to be a
problem I remember when I was the deputy
I had to read all the papers and there
was this one story about the Dubai ports
thing and I for for days it was in the
Washington Times like in the back pages
and I was like I think this is going to
be a problem and everyone blew me off
it's not going to be a problem it became
a gigantic problem this baby formula
problem is not new it's been going on
for a few months so it seems to me like
nobody is at the White House going
excuse me Mr President we're going to
have a problem here and because you have
moms who are so anxious I don't I talked
to several moms today we actually had
one on Newsroom as well she has every
family member in three states in
Kentucky area looking for a baby formula
they're looking everywhere and the White
House can close its eyes it can cover
its ears and they can scream Rick Scott
a thousand times times and it's not
going to change this fact they needed to
prepare people I'm not saying that they
can fix it overnight but they had all of
a sudden this is like the first time
they're talking about it yeah you know
it's so it go I have to say this is so
ironic I mean the media is more alarmed
by an abortion shortage than a baby
formula shortage what does that say it
is kind of interesting because the
moment this thing happened everybody
exploded but this has been going on for
a while no one gives a damn yep
interesting you got to follow the mom's
groups yeah gotta follow them listen to
the kids crying
for their baby formula I don't even know
what it is hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else